The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK.
Today we're going to continue
the topic of Consumption
Smoothing.
This sort of sequence began
with the optimal allocation
of risk bearing and what
you would see in the data.
We saw the benchmark was doing
well in many but not all cases.
And there were some examples
where coefficients on income
were higher and for
certain occupations
and certain types of income.
Then we took that same
benchmark still clinging to it
and looked at a whole different
kind of data, production data.
And we're going
to come back to it
next time when we talk
about labor supply.
But while we're on the subject
of consumption and consumption
smoothing, I thought
it would be good to go
through some
alternative models that
are widely used and
different data sets
and give you a sense of what
people do in the literature.
So a lot of this has to do with
the permanent income model.
It's just kind of the
basic sort of thing
that people rely on and
fall back on constantly
or say consumption smoothing
over the life cycle.
These markets are not complete.
They shut down a lot of the
risk contingencies allowing
households to trade only in risk
free bonds or maybe have some
other savings account which
cannot go below zero or limited
credit.
The papers were going
to cover, first one,
there's one by
Kaplan and Violante,
which is going to look at
the degree of consumption
through smoothing from this SIM,
which is Standard Incomplete
Market model.
They're also going
to simulate it.
So that's using it
two purposes there.
And we're going to
look at smoothing
through the lens of that
model and in the data
against permanent shocks
and transitory shocks.
This is a language we have
not been using so far.
But it is standard language
in this other literature,
and look at how smoothing varies
against these various shocks
[? varies ?] over
the life cycle.
The Violante paper
and others draw
on this [? Blundell, ?]
Pistaferri,
and Preston method,
which is looking
at consumption and income data.
And in fact, there is not
typically a very long time
series in the US to use.
The best is a PSID , which
used to only have food.
So part of this paper is
about how to splice together
two different databases
to create a longer panel
and measure the degree
of smoothing in the data.
Then we'll move to
Deaton and Paxson, which
is the same overall
topic but actually
quite interesting
because they're
going to be looking more at
the variance of consumption
in cross sections, which is
an implication of the models.
But you don't need these panel.
You just need a bunch of cross
sections for various years.
So effectively, if
it's representative,
you can track people by age.
And again, they do that
through a permanent income
model, a buffer stock model,
a model with borrowing
constraints, as well as in the
background, the full insurance
model, and relate it
to things in the data.
Then there's this Campbell
and Deaton paper, which
is about excess smoothness.
And I kind of smile every
time I see this title because
from the standpoint of the
permanent income model,
you should respond to
shocks to permanent income.
And they see in the
data that consumption
is smoother than that.
So they call it
excess smoothness.
My smiles come from
the fact that they
haven't considered the full
risk-sharing benchmark, which
may not fit
perfectly well either
but may be part of the
explanation in the background.
And then finally, we have
this Krueger and Perri
paper, which looks at
the US and Italian data.
And I hope we get time to say
a few words about this today
because
AUDIENCE: I'm doing
it in the recitation.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: You're
doing it in the recitation?
OK.
Yeah, I originally had this as
part of the primary lecture,
and then we thought
there wasn't enough time
in class, which may yet
turn out to be true.
And then I looked at it
again, and I really like it.
So I'm glad one way or the
other, you're going to see it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I'll do something else.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's fine.
Maybe we'll get a
lot of questions.
So what's the problem?
In the US as I was saying,
we need longitudinal data
on consumption and income.
And on consumption, we need
a comprehensive measure.
No one's been gathering
these kinds of data.
So how do people cope with it?
They could use the PS
and just look at food.
Or they could look exclusively
at the Consumer Expenditure
Survey, which has a whole
bunch of line items.
But people are not in that
sample for more than three
or four quarters.
Or you could sort of basically
create these synthetic cohorts
by sort of extrapolating
and merging,
which is increasingly a common
way to deal with the problem.
Another way to sort of
think about this upfront
is these models are
making a distinction
between permanent and transitory
shocks, but we only see income.
We don't see each of these
different kinds of shocks
individually.
So what to do about that?
You could ignore it and
just look at the response
to total income
change, which is kind
of what we've been doing,
actually, in the development
data sets.
You could use
proxies for permanent
versus transitory shocks.
For example, disability
might rightly
be thought of as a
rather permanent shock.
Short-term unemployment
might be thought
of as a transitory shock.
So that's another way to
try to deal with a problem.
And then there's sort of a
public finance tax literature.
Different people
assume different things
about different kinds of taxes.
Some tax is assumed
to be permanent,
others assumed to be transitory.
And then you kind of see how
households react to that.
So the benchmark model
people use for saying,
quote, "How much insurance is
there actually in the data?"
Is this Blundell,
Pistaferri, Preston paper,
I doubt if we'll
get to that today.
It is in the
appendix, so I have it
in the slides, time permitting.
But it's basically covariance
decomposition of the income
and consumption process.
So that's the quote
view of the data.
Then for the models, you start
with the standard incomplete
markets model, assuming no
access to contingent claims
but allowing some
kind of insurance
through buying
and selling bonds.
Now let me pause for a second,
just in case it's not clear.
And this literature uses
confusing language, actually.
If you thought about a household
in isolation or a business,
they have ups and
downs of income.
And it's clear that by
saving, you kind of smooth off
the peaks so that
higher income does not
make its way into consumption.
And likewise, in the valleys,
when income is really low,
you can carry forward
that savings to that
spot or borrow, which
makes the valley less deep.
So consumption is smooth
to a large degree,
but not completely against
these fluctuations.
What's the difference
between that
and the full risk-sharing model?
The idea there is that you
don't have-- not everyone's
facing idiosyncratic
and transitory shocks
at the same time.
So as in the Rocky
Mountains diagram,
peaks and valleys come
at different stages.
And even after you act as if a
household would do everything
that it could on its
own, you're still
left with this
asynchronous timing.
So what the risk-sharing
model is basically doing
is transferring consumption
around in the cross-section
to get even flatter consumption.
And the only thing that
would be left then,
if you believe the full
risk-sharing model,
are those shocks that
basically somehow get
left in aggregate consumption
after all that smoothing.
The only part of the
peaks and valleys
that's common across all the
households would be left.
And everything else
would be flattened out.
So this literature,
it's true that you
can do an enormous
amount of smoothing
by borrowing and lending.
But it is not true
that you can do
everything that would
be possible with greater
amounts of insurance.
Anyway, so they start
with the standard--
note the word
standard-- it's standard
for the certain branches
of the macro literature,
incomplete markets literature.
You may or may not
put on a lifecycle.
To be realistic, you'd
say, the household faith
sees a stochastic
probability of dying.
And that makes them
more and more vulnerable
as they get older and older,
in some sense, because they
can't smooth that out.
Or they have to front-load
stuff into savings
to be able to cope with
fluctuations as they get older.
So it does matter whether the
horizon is infinite or finite.
There are permanent
and transitory shocks
to earnings while they earn.
But if it's the life
cycle model as in the US,
where there is
literally retirement,
then earnings go to zero.
You may have some income
stream from social security,
and these guys
will load that in.
And you may have
some assets you've
put in a pension fund, which has
kind of an insurance component
to it, in the sense that
you're getting an income
stream from the pension but
averaging over the mortality
risk in the population.
So there's a bit of insurance
in the standard pension funds.
Another version has
borrowing limits.
There's something called
the natural borrowing
limit or the zero.
Zero is obvious.
You can't borrow
anything at all,
or you'll put just
a bound, can borrow
10% of your assets
or your income.
The natural borrowing limit
is something like this.
You always have to
repay your debt.
So you can't borrow
more than what
you could repay in the
worst possible income
realization in the future.
And then it matters a
lot what you're assuming
about the income process.
If there's a small
chance of a zero income,
and your debt is due
in that situation,
then effectively you
can't borrow at all.
So it's a rather
stringent criterion.
And then they'll take--
you'll see Kaplan and
Violante then take the model.
And they simulate, hence
the SIM, artificial data
from the model itself.
There's two reasons
for doing that.
First of all, this Blundell,
Pistaferri, Preston paper
is doing something
with the data.
It's not a direct
look at the data.
But the summary statistics
come from this BPP algorithm.
So they want us--
if you want a common ground,
which is what's in the data
through BPP, then let's look at
the data generated by the model
through BPP and compare
apples to apples.
On the other hand, when you have
a model and you simulated it,
that is the reality.
You know exactly what
the economy is like.
So they also use this--
pick up distortions,
where BPP is
kind of giving you a summary
statistic of the degree
of insurance, which is
not actually what's going
on in the underlying model.
So they use this to
look at the biases
or what can generate the bias.
The intuition there is
pretty straightforward.
Zero borrowing or limits to
borrowing are like a corner.
And you're either constrained
or you're not constrained,
so that's a non-linearity,
whereas BPP algorithm
is basically linear.
So the distortions get
introduced by the more likely
you are to be hitting corners,
the higher the distortion is.
So the standard
incomplete market model
generates an
insurance coefficient
for transitory shocks of
94% in the natural borrowing
constraint economy, or 82% in
the zero borrowing constraint
economy.
That's a coefficient
for insurance,
so that's a good thing.
Be careful you don't
get flipped around,
because we've been looking at
the degree to which consumption
fluctuates with income, so you
start to think high numbers
are bad.
But this is 1 minus that.
So for them, high
numbers means insurance,
which means a good thing.
Those are numbers,
94, 82, compared
to the BPP run on the
actual data, which is 95.
So that's an excellent fit.
But when they look at
the insurance coefficient
for permanent shocks,
it's 22% or 7%,
depending in the model what
you assume about credit.
But in the actual
data, it's 36%.
And here already you're
seeing this recurrent theme
that there's better
smoothing against even
the permanent shocks in the
data than these models allow.
And then if you looked
at the life cycle
through the lens
of the model, you
would see better insurance
as people get older.
But in the data, it's not there.
There's no age
profile in the data.
So the model-- another
way to say this,
is generating too
much consumption
smoothing for the older
workers, relative to the data,
or too little
smoothing for workers
in the early stage
of their lifecycle,
relative to the data.
If you're skeptical, you've
got to be skeptical about BPP
because it's supposed
to be, quote,
a "fact" that they're finding.
We'll look at some of that
data though through the lens
of the cross-sectional
distributions
when we get to
Deaton and Paxson.
And then you'll kind
of see something else.
And I haven't thought about
how to reconcile that yet.
So what I said about the
reliability, when they simulate
and use the data
from the model, it's
fine for the transitory
shocks, largely.
But it tends to underestimate
the true coefficient
for the permanent shocks.
That's actually making
this situation worse
because then the
BPP measure, which
shows good insurance for
the permanent shocks,
is a lower bound estimate of the
actual insurance in the data,
so there's an even
greater divergence.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can I just
make sure I understood?
So in the data, we
see changes in how
I smoothed over the lifecycle.
But in the model, we
don't see any changes?
Or have I got it
wrong way around?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: No, it's
almost the other way around.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So the model we see it as
[? profile, ?] but in real life
we don't see--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So that seems kind
of counterintuitive, I guess,
to us.
Wouldn't we expect-- maybe I'm
thinking of a different method.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah,
the problem is taking--
the model is
generating differences
by age because of
the life cycle.
But the data does not show that.
So that's why you get this
sort of odd-looking statement
that looks like it's more
criticism of the model.
But it's of the model
relative to the flat data.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
once we [INAUDIBLE]..
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Someone once said,
if the data don't
fit the model, it
must be something
wrong with the data.
So we're feeling
at pressure here.
I didn't say that.
How can you get more
smoothing to generate
less sensitivity of consumption
to these permanent shocks?
Because again, there's-- it
seemed to get turned around
so easily.
There's more smoothing in
the data than in the models.
So you want the model to allow
more smoothing to catch up
to the data.
And one thing you could
do is give households
a little more information
about the future.
And then the idea--
it's a smoothing model.
So if they know things are
going to get better or worse,
they can take actions now
and adjust consumption.
So the overall profile
that would result
would be smoother if they
could anticipate future income,
rather than having to react
to sudden information.
And a close cousin of
that is to move away
from some random walk, to put in
some serially correlated income
process.
And that, actually,
does a better job
in getting the model
to match the data.
As I said, so far in this class,
we haven't talked too, too much
about these income processes.
But it's really front
and center here.
What you assume about an
income process, is it IID?
Is it autoregressive,
for that matter,
with high frequency data?
What about the seasonality
and everything?
That makes you aware of
both the great strength
and vulnerability of the
risk-sharing model, which
says it doesn't matter what
time it is or what state it is.
Just add up total consumption
and smooth it out.
There's a fixed static
rule for allocating risk.
There could be predictable
periodic seasonal fluctuations
or trends in income.
It doesn't matter for
the risk-sharing model.
But here with incomplete
models, it matters much more.
AUDIENCE: You say that
two is better than one.
If it's AR, it's
going to be better
than predicting the future.
But AR, to a degree, is also the
ability to predict the future.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah,
it's very related.
AUDIENCE: So there's
something else from the AR
that's making it better?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: I guess
there are other ways
to predict the future.
Even if the process itself
is not autoregressive,
you could get signals about what
it's going to be in the future.
AUDIENCE: That's
not as good as--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's
what the claim is, yeah.
That's what they find.
So here's the model, finally.
There is no aggregate
uncertainty.
Agents work until retirement,
but they don't die then.
There's a probability
[? z ?] of surviving.
This is, I guess, retirement
is a really bad thing
because if you
don't retire, you're
going to live with
probability 1.
So anyway, this is
a simplification.
So they only start using these
actuarial tables after age
60 or 65, whatever they
put in for retirement age.
So it's maximizing
discounted expected utility,
common utility function.
We've been doing
a lot of that too.
Beta is the standard discount
rate. [? Z ?] is this--
you only get the utility
if you're alive, basically.
So that's a standard adjustment
to the discount rate.
The income process
is a bit complicated.
First of all, there is a
possible nonstochastic trend,
sort of the deterministic
part, which could move income
along with T. And then you
have income, quote, "standard."
Here's the decomposition.
Income is equal to z, which
is this permanent thing,
in this case, entirely a
random walk, and epsilon,
which is the IID
transitory shock.
So these papers use
different notation.
And this paper, z, is permanent,
and epsilon is transitory.
And eta is another shock.
And that's the shock to
permanent income, basically.
So in expectation, you expect
your income to be what it was.
You expect the permanent
part of your income
to be exactly what
it was last period.
But this thing will
move that around.
And then these have variances--
sigma eta, sigma epsilon.
The budget constraint, again,
is like this bond, which you may
or may not be able to short.
So you've got your
assets from last period.
That's earning interest,
plus your income.
So this is like your
disposable income,
which you can spend on
consumption and assets,
going forward.
Watch the subscript.
It'll drive you crazy.
It does me.
This is dated t plus 1.
But it's decided on a t,
and consumption is also
decided on a t.
So in some of these
formulas, you're
going to see a mysterious
interest rate adjustment.
And it has to do with this sort
of convention of the timing.
This looks the same,
except as I said,
it's like a pension
fund in your assets.
So effectively,
this gets adjusted.
It's not like everyone has
their own individual retirement
account, which you draw down.
There's a pool of money there.
Some people continue to
live, and some don't.
And so those-- in other words,
if you're, quote, "lucky,"
and you keep living,
you could actually
draw more from the fund
than what you put in there.
And this is a very convenient
way to kind of adjust.
Oh, and if you're retired
you get your social security
benefits.
They're going to put
some numbers in here
from the life cycle
literature and other sources,
using various US data sets.
And I'm not going to
dwell on the numbers.
But this is a classic
picture of the life cycle.
So here are the
earnings going up.
You guys are down here
somewhere, on average.
You can expect to do
better eventually.
And then you get to be 60,
and it doesn't go to zero.
That's if you were a US citizen,
that's where you start drawing.
Actually, you could
just be an immigrant.
You start drawing social
security benefits.
With this profile, you try
to keep consumption steady.
It's not completely flat.
It just looks flat
relative to everything else
on this diagram.
It's actually
increasing somewhat.
But the goal of the
life cycle smoothing
is to try to have more or
less steady consumption.
Again, this is-- there
are two lines here.
There's a natural borrowing
constraint and zero borrowing
constraint.
It doesn't make too much
different for consumption.
I guess here the zero
borrowing constraint
looks more constraining.
So when you're young,
expecting on average higher
future income, you might
want to borrow against that
and repay the debt later.
But you hit one or the
other of these constraints,
so you can't do that too much.
Of course, the gorilla in the
room is this wealth profile.
And that's where all the
action is, basically.
In fact, you're basically
over the life cycle,
accumulating and then
deaccumulating wealth.
That's what's keeping
consumption steady.
And remember, when income
goes to virtually zero,
apart from social
security, you've
got to live off the
interest in your--
you have social security, plus
the adjusted actuarial interest
off the pension fund.
And that's typically
a lot smaller flow
than was your previous income.
So you need a ton
of assets to be
able to survive into old age.
This is drawn out, looks
like to 90 something, 95.
That could have
been shown first,
but that's kind of a summary
of the life cycle model
and what Kaplan and
Violante are doing,
and they're generating these
smoothing statistics from date
by date with shocks.
But this is the overall
pattern you would see.
Let's go to Deaton and Paxson
for a very different look at it
through the lens of
these cross sections.
The starting point, again, is
that with a permanent income
hypothesis, consumption
of each person
should basically
follow a random walk.
Again, the idea is
you should basically
be eating at the level
of your permanent income.
And when you're permanent
income is shock,
then your consumption is shock.
But the implication
that consumption
follows a random walk
means, basically, you'll
see the equations for it.
Date by date by
date, you get hit
with positive or negative
shocks and their IID.
So basically, some
people have their ups
and other people
have their downs.
So you start getting
this fanning out.
And then you go-- then you take
the cohort that is still all
alike.
Go one more period.
They have ups and downs.
Those guys fan out a bit.
So the cross-sectional
distribution
just keeps getting
fatter and fatter
with bigger and bigger tails.
So all of the slides,
basically, are
going to be about this
increasing consumption
inequality in the cross-section.
They measure it by
the standard deviation
of the log of consumption,
age group by age group.
But again, if you thought
about full risk-sharing,
you get this dramatic contrast.
At least for the cases where
people have uniform risk
aversion and so on, then
we know that what pins down
the level of your
consumption, on average, is
going to be your Pareto weight.
And you kind of have
those fixed at t equals 0.
That's going to
fix the intercepts.
And your consumption might
fluctuate with aggregate shocks
around that, but it's
not going to move
with age or anything else.
So basically, the
cross-sectional dispersion
of consumption does not increase
in the full risk-sharing model.
But you will see that in the
data, depending on the country,
it does happen.
You have to be a little
mindful of going back and forth
between this cross-sectional
age-dependent inequality,
and inequality for the
economy as a whole,
because demographics can shift.
Even if you give
me someone's age,
and I'll tell you sort of what
the cross-sectional dispersion
is in the population, when you
have demographics going on,
you may have an
increasing number
of young people or old people,
depending on the economy.
So you're basically taking
an age-weighted average
as the demographics shift, and
that will shift inequality.
So an issue in
this literature is
how much of aggregate
inequality can
be explained by these kinds
of life cycle smoothing
considerations, and
how much by baby booms
versus fertility
drops and all of that.
So this is kind of nice because
they have the US, Britain,
and cross sections, which
are three countries that
have a quite ample amount of
cross-sectional consumption,
for that matter,
also, income data.
They're going to use 47
annual surveys spread out
over the three
countries and look
at the implications of
these models for the kind
of cross-sectional
inequality and see
what it takes to explain it.
So how does this work exactly?
So we want to follow
cohorts over time.
We cannot follow an
individual person over time,
because it's not panel data.
But you make the assumption
that, for example,
if you see a bunch of
31-year-olds in 1976 in Taiwan,
you're getting a good
summary statistic
of the cross-sectional
dispersion
of their consumption in 1976.
And then you go to 1977,
and they are now 32.
Actually, "they"
isn't quite correct,
because it's a
different set of people.
But again, you hope
you have enough of them
and that the basic
assumptions are correct,
that you can take these
kinds of statistics
as representative of
what you would have seen
if you could have
been able to continue
to track the same people.
Some people actually think
this is better than panel data,
in the sense that you
don't have to worry
about people dropping
out, and the data
becomes unrepresentative.
And there is some truth to that.
There are issues about
whether the data are coming
from households or individuals.
You have to make
some adjustments
for household composition.
And the surveys being used
here are the Personal Income
Distribution Survey in Taiwan,
the Consumer Expenditure Survey
in the US-- that's the same
one we've referred to before--
and this Family Expenditure
Survey in Great Britain.
So it takes a bit of
staring to get used to this.
So we start out with people
who are age 15 in 1976.
And they kind of start
here in calendar time, 1982
or something like that.
Again, we don't track
the same people.
But we can look what happens.
This paper is not the most
recent thing in the world.
It's just a really nice one.
So they basically stopped
using data after 1990.
So we go back to
the 1976 survey,
all the way up to the 1990
survey, with repeated cross
sections and looking what
happens to inequality
in this cohort, as they age.
These guys were 15.
These guys were 20 in 1976.
So they start older, and they're
going to end a bit older.
And then you keep going here
to the aged 55 people in 1976
and so on.
These are pretty flat,
then these profiles
start to pick up.
You kind of in your mind
sort of can imagine.
And I'll show you
what happens when
we splice all this together.
AUDIENCE: It seems like
a lot of the action
is brought about by the--
towards those
middle-aged cohorts.
Those who start middle-aged did
in '76, like, from 40 to 55.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Let me just--
AUDIENCE: The rest
is kind of flat.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Let me
just jump because I--
those are the three countries.
Here's what's going to--
when you use all the
surveys over all the years
and just focus on the age--
yeah, so you see this.
You're right.
You see this is pretty
flat, and then it
picks up around age whatever,
45 or 50 or something.
And these are the results
from the other countries.
AUDIENCE: So is
there any explanation
for why that's the case?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, we're
going to get into that.
You'll be sorry you asked.
AUDIENCE: And only in Taiwan.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Huh?
The others seem to be--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK, so
this is kind of flat,
and then it kind of comes up,
and then it flattens out again.
So Taiwan is flattening out,
although, unfortunately,
the cohorts are getting
thin the older they are.
So you get some
sort of shaky data
because you can't
average quite so well.
This one flattens out.
Great Britain kind
of flattens out.
The US, I don't
know, wasn't very
steeply climbing to begin with.
It's not so obvious.
This kind of looks concave.
This looks concave
but almost linear.
This actually has almost
an inflection point
and then comes in.
So the question is
concave, convex, et cetera,
and that's where we'll
do a little modeling.
By the way, you saw a little
bit about demographics
when we did China.
One of those explanations
of the savings rates,
et cetera, wasn't so much
about state-owned enterprise
as it was the different
demographics, and young savers
in China, and sort of
debt-loaded or less
saving-inclined households
in the US, and so different
demographics.
Just to remind you,
it's not the first time
that we've thought
about demographics.
So it's possible to put that--
there's trivial demographics
in some of the macro models,
in the sense that they
start with a lifecycle model
or two-period overlapping
generations model.
But we haven't actually
focused on much
of this in the sort of
micro part of the class.
So this is what I said in words.
They claim Britain
is slightly convex.
I didn't see that just now.
And again, don't
misread those things
to be measures of
the total increases
or decreases in
inequality, because
the demographic structure
is moving around by age
over those 20 or so years.
Let's start with the basics.
Here is basically Hall's
permanent income implication
for consumption.
Consumption should
essentially be a random walk.
And it's only moving
around because
of the innovations or the
shock to permanent income.
I think that was
[? JPE, ?] 1970.
The dates here, I think
it was in the [? JPE. ?]
There are assumptions.
This isn't always true.
He assumed quadratic utility,
additive preferences,
discount rates equal to
interest rates, and, I think,
another life cycle.
This is supposed to
be an innovation,
so for every person
at least, there's
no covariance between
lagged consumption
and this innovation,
because it wasn't
supposed to be predictable.
That's the same conversation,
just how much, if anything,
you see about the future.
Here, zero is seen.
So I described this in words.
But basically, if it were
stable like this on average,
then consumption dispersion
shouldn't be changing.
But you're just
layering on repeatedly,
shock after shock after shock.
So with that zero
covariance assumption,
the variances are increasing
by the variance of that [? u ?]
t shock.
And basically, if you started
plotting these distributions,
the one at t is going
to have fatter tails
than the one at t minus 1.
So t minus 1, [? quotient, ?]
first order stochastically
dominates.
You have to be a little
bit careful throughout all
of this stuff.
You think about
things in the point
of view of a person
tracking a person over time.
But that statement
about c t and [? u t ?]
is actually a statement about
the cross section, as well as
the intertemporal dimension.
This model typically
didn't have taste shifters
or heterogeneous preferences.
You can put those things in.
Depending on how you put them
in, it does make a difference.
Arguably, if we hadn't done
the demographics right,
but they claim--
Deaton and Paxson
claim for Taiwan,
then you kind of need
preference shocks to help
with the observed dispersion.
Here is the basic sort
of budget equation again.
And I'm afraid each
one of these papers
kind of has a different
convention about the timing.
So it's really kind of hard
to keep tracking and track it.
But basically, you have
sources and uses of money.
The sources are previous
assets plus interest.
The uses are-- source
also is income,
and the use is consumption.
And then what you don't
spend accumulates on
to the next period.
If you do do the life cycle
with a terminal date, for sure,
say, age 99 or
whatever you want,
then you can actually
get a formula closed form
for consumption, under these
other maintained assumptions.
And basically, it's
kind of saying,
consumption ought to equal
something about the return
stream through the
interest rate on assets,
and something about the
forward-looking part, which is
expected future income shocks.
So this kind of helps you see
how future things are already--
if this is going
to be very high,
for example, then this
is already going up.
So it's kind of smooth against--
or low, vise versa.
It's tricky with a finite
horizon and a cap t
because there is a coefficient
premultiplying this,
but it's for that
reason, basically.
Obviously, the closer you
are to the end to cap t,
the less smoothing
you can accomplish.
And that's inherited
into this formula.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: The shocks here
are IID all the time?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes.
Well, the shock to
permanent income is IID.
But permanent income is
an autoregressive process.
The standard incomplete markets
model had an infinite horizon.
And it had a discount
rate equal to 1,
or basically beta times
1 plus r equals 1.
In the finite
horizon case, beta,
that thing premultiplying
consumption,
turns out if you stare
at it, is concave.
We're already beginning to
anticipate these formulas
and decreasing in t.
And if you go back to
those two equations,
you'll get kind of a
simplified version,
that beta t times the
change in consumption
is equal to this, quote,
"consumption innovation."
And here's a formula for
the consumption innovation,
which is, again, the
difference in expectation.
So you're forecasting
the future all the time.
But you're also
getting these shocks.
So as of t and t minus 1,
you were forecasting y t
at t plus k.
Sorry, y of t plus k, not either
to either, to t or t minus 1.
It could be 10 years out.
And you're constantly
adjusting your expectations,
based on the current
information you
have from the income process.
And you're summing up over
all those future income
shocks and discounting
backwards to get
these, quote, "innovations."
So then imagine starting
this out at some date t
equals 0, and then t equals
1, and t equals 2, and so on.
And you could just
write out, literally,
consumption in each
one of those dates.
And of course, when you go
from one date to another,
you get hit with this shock.
And you're premultiplying
by the beta,
so you end up with this,
an explicit formula
for consumption equal to
its initial given level.
Plus, the beta moves
on the right-hand side,
this sort of beta discounted.
But it's not beta in
the preference function.
This is that beta thing that
had to do with little t,
big T, and all of
that, that took
care of the lifecycle
considerations.
So finally, we see
again the familiar theme
that the variance
at t is related
to the initial cross-sectional
variance at zero,
plus the sum of variance terms.
So the issue-- so
roughly speaking,
it looks like, yeah, it ought
to increase-- unless you retire
and you have no more
things then forecast,
then this piece goes away.
But before that happens,
you're looking at future
and making expectations
of future income.
So you just keep adding on.
So that's why inequality
is increasing in the data,
through the lens
of these models.
And then the issue is, is it
linear or concave or convex?
That has to do with
this beta and also
has to do with what we
can infer about sigma,
about the consumption
innovations.
So in response to
your question, if we
assume this
innovation is entirely
white noise, normalized
by the interest rate,
then sigma square eta
at t is a constant
that doesn't depend on t.
And this is the
resulting expression
with the sigma square
eta pulled out front.
And then the
convexity is entirely
due to this beta
thing, which if you
start taking some derivatives
and so on, it's a bit messy.
You can convince yourself
that that thing is convex.
Here's an orthogonal example.
I guess, [? Jan, ?] I
jumped the gun a bit
because this actually
allows something a bit
different, which is this
autoregressive thing.
This is IID, and then
this is autoregressive,
so this income
process is persistent.
It's a bit odd because this
was the innovation that had
to do with the innovation to--
the right-hand side had to
do with all those expectation
differences.
So it's like, let's just assume
it looks something like this.
This is more explicit
about the income process.
And you can derive the
formula for the change
in consumption, where this
beta r thing is now this mess.
And it turns out,
this will be concave
if you can sign this expression.
And it may also be
decreasing in age
if this is true, and so
actually, except for some days
of theta, both things--
So two of those three
countries, the profile
was, say, not concave.
It could have been linear, which
is a weak case of concavity,
or even convex.
And so basically, then
you could rule this out
because these are--
this kind of persistence
would give you concavity.
But you don't see that.
But then we have
the sort of paradox
that something like these
white noise processes
must be closer to
the truth if we're
going to get convex profiles.
But that's an assumption
about the income process.
And in particular,
one way to get it
is to say that there's a large
stationary component to income.
So you're not getting those
innovations in your forecasts.
And we don't see
that in the data.
Income profiles
are not stationary.
There's heavy
lifecycle components.
So nothing's perfect, I guess.
Every model is a benchmark.
Almost every model
is going to deliver
something that might fit well.
Otherwise, we're probably
not reading it in a journal.
Or it may actually
also generate things
that are not consistent
with the data,
and if you're a good scholar,
you're reporting that too.
What about the permanent
income and the dispersion
of income by age?
So again, disposable
income takes
on this form, which is
sort of asset return
stream, plus income.
And then you use it for
consumption and savings,
adjusting for where you
are in the life cycle.
Or you could take
the difference.
Savings is the
difference between income
and this beta-adjusted
consumption.
And some of these models
you can get a closed form
expression for savings, namely
the so-called Campbell's "rainy
day," which is really
kind of cool, which is you
save enough at t to be able
to cover the discounted
shortfalls in sort of
these earnings innovations.
So you want to smooth those out.
And you save just enough
to do that in expectation.
Anyway, so we're rewriting
disposable income
equal to the savings component.
We already had that,
less the savings--
plus the savings component.
Sorry, I get confused
because savings was negative.
It used to be here,
and now it's out here.
Savings is not negative,
but these innovations
are negative because you
save to cover shortfalls.
And then you get
implications here
for if one thing
is a random walk,
and the other thing
then the sum of two things
that are random walks
is also a random walk.
So basically, savings ought to
be stationary in that sense.
And it ought to be
dispersing at the rate
that consumption is dispersing.
And they don't see that
in the data either.
And in particular,
earnings is dispersing,
which is a point that was made
on the other slide as well.
And then finally,
I guess this is
like the fourth version
of something that starts
to look like the same thing.
Most of those
analytic expressions
were assuming something
like quadratic utility.
That's how you managed to get
this really tight reduced form
analytic expression.
If you don't do that, if you
have constant relative risk
aversion, for example, or a
more general utility function,
than the Euler
equation basically
is going to equate the marginal
utility today to something
like marginal utility tomorrow.
We might say, well, where's
the expectation operator?
Instead, the shock is put over
here on the right-hand side.
So this is like
an Euler equation.
If this were 0, and
the interest rate
was equal to this
delta discount rate,
then basically the marginal
utility of consumption,
if we could deduce it,
would be not going anywhere.
It would be the same over time.
But again, with
r equal to delta,
we kick on this extra
orthogonal shock,
which makes the marginal utility
of consumption dispersing
in the future, relative today.
And you can even
have r not equal
to delta, as long as
delta is greater than r.
The same logic applies
because you've kind of like
amplified this thing, carrying
it through to tomorrow,
along with the u shock.
So that's another way to get
at the variance of consumption
increasing, depending on what
you assume about the utility
function.
Some functions, though, have
a force that go the other way.
In particular, if you're
really, really into it,
you get into third derivatives.
But when you're really
sort of cautious,
that lambda is convex.
So you're taking a second
derivative of already
the marginal utility.
That's why I commented about
third derivatives of utility
functions.
And that, if you start
staring at this thing,
can actually push you back
against this dispersion
of consumption.
So I'm having a sense that
this is going on and on.
But the point is to take each
of these different forces
and then tell stories about
what must be true in Taiwan,
versus Britain,
versus the US, to try
to rationalize what
we're seeing in the data,
and similarly, here.
So let's just say three words
about excess smoothness.
To repeat, the
lifecycle model implies
that shocks to permanent income
should be fully incorporated
into consumption,
while innovations
to the transitory part are not.
Basically, all the income--
all the transitory
income fluctuations
should not be appearing in
consumption, which actually
is something we've
talked about with regards
to the full risk-sharing
model, except there,
we didn't make this
distinction between
transitory and permanent.
But when they go and
look at the data,
they say, hey,
consumption is too smooth.
It doesn't react to innovations
in the permanent component.
And other people have
found something similar.
And we're inching
forward to models
where we're going to need
to modify the models.
We're going to have to
introduce something else,
like private information,
and more on that in a second.
Yup?
AUDIENCE: Why do
all these assume
the market is incomplete?
So maybe just because the
market is relatively complete,
so these [INAUDIBLE]?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: So
that's my gut reaction.
Actually, so this
Pavoni paper puts
in sort of some unobserved
savings and other things.
And it actually comes
close to the data.
So it isn't all the way
toward full insurance,
but it is more full insurance
than what these models imply.
So it's trying to
reconcile the puzzle.
I'd like to think
I'm quite agnostic.
In my rural [? Thai ?]
data, certainly,
when you include other variables
and not just consumption,
we see rejections of
full risk-sharing.
I'm not determined
to always find
full risk-sharing in the data.
But likewise, I would hope
these guys aren't clinging
to the permanent income model
as the only game in town,
because it's clearly
also suffering
from its own sort of anomalies,
relative to the data.
And there's no reason
to think that it
has to be this same model for
every village or every country,
and actually,
Deaton and Paxson's
stuff, looking at the
cross sections, kind
of saying that it's different.
It could be different
in different countries
if you're going to try
to reconcile the observed
movements.
But anyway, you guys need to
know about this literature.
You need to have a view of the
different consumption smoothing
literature.
I guess I should
also say sort of,
it looks as though it's a
macro-ish, US-ish literature.
But that's not true, certainly,
for Paxson and Deaton, who
are avid development economists
and looking at that data
from developing countries.
And likewise, the initial
risk-sharing stuff,
that wasn't peculiar
to development.
That was being tested
by Cochrane and Mace
and so on in US data.
So there's really
never been this idea
that somehow macro is in one
room, using one subset of data,
and micro is another room,
using another subset.
That would be rather silly.
So we really need to know
how all these models work.
So this is, again, Campbell's
saving for a rainy day.
It's repeated because
it's a different paper.
They look at--
Campbell and Deaton now
are looking at US data
and saying the labor
income is described
by this autoregressive
process with a positive serial
correlation.
And what that means is
innovations are, quote unquote,
"more than permanent,"
not just random walk-ish,
but basically--
Now you get even
into more trouble
because if consumption should
reflect the innovations
to permanent income, and
what you see in innovations
is more than permanent,
that means consumption
should respond even more.
And it's not, in the data,
responding that much.
It's much less variable.
So either they're
getting this fact wrong.
Or, again, maybe the households
have more information somehow.
Or they have stupid
expectations or whatever.
These guys were not able
to resolve the puzzle.
If you want to see the
equations, there they are.
I'm not sure at this point
that it adds all that much
more to the discussion.
And this is what I was saying
about Attanasio and Pavoni.
So the plan is--
there's a little
more coming today.
Don't worry.
Or you might say, oh, darn.
But the plan in the
ordering of the lectures
is to do labor
and wage variation
and smoothing, adding labor
supply to a consumption model,
and talk about elasticities
and sensitivities.
That will be done with both
the full risk-sharing model,
as well as a version of these
incomplete market models.
So we'll see what survives,
depending on what you assume
about the market structure.
And then we're going to go to
have a whole lecture on models
that are much more explicit
about moral hazard, unobserved
income, and so on.
And this Pavoni paper is one
of them in that literature.
We're not going to
cover it in class.
So actually, the front part of
the lecture was about this BPP.
It's probably a bit
mysterious what it was,
so we can review
that for a second.
The idea is that you
postulate that log of earnings
takes on this process where
x is a vector of shocks,
a is some vector
of coefficients,
the shocks are IID, the x's
are, and they have variances.
This allows a whole bunch of
stuff, not only just random
walks, but autoregressive
integrated moving
average processes on income.
This is what you see.
And then this
general formulation
allows a bunch of different
specifications, which they're
going to try to estimate.
And somehow what
they want to back out
is this insurance coefficient.
So here's, again, how it's
easy to get turned around.
This is how a sort of,
like, quote unquote,
a regression coefficient
of how consumption
is moving with this particular
shock, inferred somehow.
But 1 minus that is then
the degree of insurance
because when consumption
doesn't move with that shock,
this is zero.
And so insurance is like,
perfect, measured at 1.
And you could put
t's on these things
if you sort the data by
age, which came up earlier.
So we don't really see
all those permanent
versus transitory shocks.
You kind of have to
infer them, somehow.
And this is a bit like
using some assumed function
on the income process,
and then filtering
the data through that function
and looking at the covariance
with income change.
But they don't just
do three alone,
because this would be a
statement about income alone.
They jointly estimate this
function, g, essentially,
jointly with consumption.
So for example, if
you assume income
took on this classic form
that we were actually
tracking through the
lectures, then income
would be the sum of a random
walk with its own innovation
and variance and
epsilon, which would
be this IID transitory shock.
If you believe this to be the
structure, and there are many,
many other candidates, then
you take a first difference.
And by construction
then, what would be left
would be this innovation in
the permanent part and a time
difference in the
transitory part, which
is still transitory.
So then the consumption
model tells you about--
puts restrictions on how
the change in consumption
should be responding, basically
taking advantage of the time
delays.
As you go back like,
two, three periods,
there is nothing that
happened that far back that's
influencing anything
at all today.
So those past data kind of
become predetermined variables,
almost as if they
were instruments.
And so that kind of mysterious
notation about g on y, this
is a version of it,
postulating a model
and then going back far
enough time, so you would see,
basically, zero covariance.
So here it is, actually.
This g is just basically
the time difference
in income at t plus 1.
And given the other
assumptions they make,
you back out some of the
key things that you want.
For example, how on
earth are we going
to know about the variance
of the transitory shocks
if we never see
transitory shocks?
Basically, that turns out to be
the covariance of two things we
do see, the time difference
of consumption at income at t
and the time difference
of income at t plus 1.
Hopefully, you're
seeing the spirit
of this, if not following
every line of the algebra.
So that's where we
get that object.
And how would you
get the variance
of the permanent income
part, the innovation
to permanent income?
Remember, that thing is
persisting over time.
So it's a bit more complicated.
It turns out to be this
daunting object, which
is to-- and everything
here you see.
That's point number one.
It's the covariance of the
time difference of income
at t, against the sum of the
changes in income at t minus 1,
t and t plus 1.
So there, again, you see this
sort of time structure at work.
The spirit of it is go
back far enough in time
so everything is predetermined.
And this is the
covariance of consumption
with that permanent shock.
So this is a key object.
Remember, that insurance formula
is, how much is consumption
moving with the innovation
to permanent income?
It all seems quite mysterious,
but here is an explicit formula
for how they get it.
So clearly, it's a
linear model, using
a lot of these variance
covariance formulas,
given the assumed structure.
They don't have to--
their starting point
could have been something else.
As I said, you had
these ARIMA processes,
but it is some structure.
When you specify the order
of the moving average part
and the order of the
autoregressive part,
you get restrictions
on the data.
So hopefully that helps
resolve some of the mysteries
about what this BPP algorithm
and what they do to the data
to measure these insurance
against idiosyncratic and
permanent shocks.
So I'm going to
leave for [? Whit ?]
to do the version of smoothing,
a bit in the Italian data.
But I will just say,
by way of motivation,
it's again looking
at various models,
although they're
not exactly nested,
and looking at the
responses of consumption
to innovations, but also
of wealth to innovations.
So we saw in my data sort of
how wealth in various lectures
is moving around in
the cross section
and moving around over time.
We talked about
responses to shocks
and whether they're using
savings accounts and so on.
So these guys in their own way
are doing something similar.
And the paper backs
out the movements
in consumption and
wealth that are predicted
from certain kinds
of innovations,
but not just between this year
and next year, but this year
and two years from now, all
the way up to six years,
or even longer.
So you kind of get the
sort of time profiles
of responsiveness.
And very much in the spirit of
what we're talking about today,
yet again, a bit different,
those response patterns
are very different,
depending on whether you're
talking about the permanent
income model or the life cycle
buffer stock type model.
That's all for today.